- Good morning, everyone.
Welcome to "AWS re:Invent."
I'm Andre Barreira, Managing
Director from Accenture.
It's a real pleasure to
be here with my colleagues
from Illumia and Accenture,
Daniel Salvador, and Gustavo.
Today we show you how Illumia
and Accenture partner with AWS
to reinvent customer
service across 11 countries.
But before dive into the solution,
let's take a quick look at Illumia.
The company at the heart of reinvention.
(gentle somber music)
(dramatic rousing music)
(upbeat rousing music)
And to kick things off, I will
hand it to Daniel Figueirido.
The CEO and the founder of Illumia.
- Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
For me, it's a real pleasure to be here.
Thank you, Andre, for this introduction
and to have the chance
to work so many times
during my career together, yeah?
You do something wrong
in your previous life.
I dunno. (laughs)
My name is Daniel Figueirido.
I am the CEO and founder of Illumia.
My last name is quite unpronounced,
so everybody say me, Danny or Figa, yeah?
And you know, when I arrive here,
I look very familiar faces, yeah?
I have friends in different
parts of the world,
so I am glad to meet you here.
So, let me start with,
how many of you are
coming from Latin America?
Raise your hands. Good.
So, (speaking in foreign language) yeah?
Thank you for being here.
Let me try to introduce
Illumia and Grupo Werthein.
Grupo Werthein is a private economic group
in Latin America.
It's an Argentine group
that started business in many industries.
Media tech, insurance, banking, IT,
agribusiness, and constructions,
and probably others that I don't remember.
And also in terms of IT.
So, we are part of Grupo Werthein.
Illumia born as a result of
the impact of digitalization,
the impact of Gen AI.
The disruption that Gen AI is creating
in everything that we are doing, yeah?
So, there is a strong need of efficiency
and strong need of treating customers
in many of the companies that we manage.
And we needed to do this right.
And let me tell you one thing.
We try many times for doing projects,
for doing transformation.
To do and to implement Gen AI
in our business process at
scale is not transformation.
It's re:Invent as Amazon is
saying or a kind of revolution.
That's why we created Illumia.
What we do and what we offer
to the market. Three things.
Customer service as a,
Customer Care as a Service,
or Customer Journey as a Service.
Automation as a Service.
And also MarTech solutions.
Campaigns, how to manage
and to monetize data
in the different companies
and the different clients
that we are managing.
And obviously, business
transformation outsourcing.
In 2002, Grupo Werthein bought
from AT&T, DirecTV and Sky.
Sky is the name that
DirecTV is used in Brazil.
And from that on, we started
a very huge transformation
and getting very huge
process of, you know,
getting efficient and
transforming the company.
And Illumia was a key player
on that transformation.
And DirecTV in Latin America is operating
12 different countries.
The entire Latin America, the Caribbean,
and also Puerto Rico.
So as a context, because
you probably listen
to Grupo Werthein, to Illumia,
to many different things,
and it's important to put
some context on who we are.
And let me try to put some
challenges that we faced.
And not necessarily the
ones that you're facing,
but we faced those, yeah?
We talk and we get promises
around digital first
for customer care for many years.
And how many of you listen the same things
and at the end is still
contact center, yeah?
Raise your hands. How many?
How many? It's our challenge, yeah?
Second, you know, customer data.
We have data lakes, we have
data all over the places
and it is a nightmare.
A real nightmare how to deal with this.
And more important, how to monetize data
at the time that we want to provide
a better service to our companies,
a better services to our clients.
Raise your hands.
Who are facing the same problem, yeah?
Okay. Very huge problem.
And the last one, and not less important.
Everybody in Latin America
is doing MVPs, books,
and many tries in order to
use Gen AI in their processes.
And at the end of the day, how to measure
and how to identify results are not so,
it's not so evident, yeah?
The issue of tokenization
and how to consume different platforms
sometimes is diluting or,
and in some points the
efficiency is not relevant, yeah?
So, those are the changes that we faced,
probably are the changes
that many of you are facing
in your companies.
And we started from
these challenges, yeah?
What we are doing at Illumia,
if we need to define.
Obviously, technology is
what we are investing in
and what we are managing.
But at the end, we are not
selling technology, yeah?
We are selling outcomes.
We are selling what we call
a Service as a Software.
We are selling our
clients and our companies
that we are intensive use.
We are doing intensive use of technology,
but at the end we are not trying to charge
or to transfer that technology to anybody.
We are selling business outcomes, yeah?
And we have models of pricing
and the way that we operate
and deliver these services,
and we build that based
on specific outcome, yeah?
Transactions or the driver
this, that are, you know,
linking the results with the business case
that our clients are producing.
So, this is what we are doing.
The idea today is to
present some of the cases
that we are managing and how
we are dealing with all these,
is all these challenges in
Latin America and in our places.
We are working with an
ecosystems of strategic partners.
We cannot do this alone, yeah?
Obviously, Amazon is a strategic partner.
Accenture that is hosting this session
is a strategic partner.
But we have others, yeah?
We have nice, we have
ESPs in Latin America
because we are offering
end-to-end solutions
for our clients.
So, this is Illumia.
We are going right now
to moving to how we are managing this
and how we are delivering
what I am presenting today.
- Hello, everyone.
I'm Lumi, the AI agent from Illumia.
Illumia was born with a clear purpose
in partnership with Accenture and AWS,
to transform how companies
connect with their customers
where empathy, agility, and
intelligence coexist seamlessly.
Let me share a bit more about
how our business model works.
But first, a few numbers
that speak for themselves.
According to market benchmarks,
companies that adopted
Generative AI and customer
service have reduced
operational costs by up to 40%,
increased first contact
resolution by up to 70%,
boosted conversion rates
through data monetization
by up to 50%, and improved
NPS by as much as 25 points.
Illumia delivers what few
traditional organizations can.
Customer care that is
empathetic, efficient,
scalable, and secure.
We offer flexible commercial models,
including outcome-based engagements,
business-aligned pricing,
and even the integration of
internal or third-party teams
under an outsourcing model.
Thank you for allowing
me to share a glimpse
of Illumia with you.
See you soon.
- Thank you, Lumi, for the introduction.
I will pass this to Salvador Alvarez.
Salvador Alvarez is the Chief
Commercial Officer of Illumia.
Also a great friend and he
will continue to explain the,
how we deliver these challenges.
- Excellent. Well, thank you very much.
Thanks everybody for this.
So, as Daniel said, you know,
we have been working for
years in this industry,
talking with different
customers in the region,
and we always find the same
answer when it comes to AI.
It's sometimes it's failing
to deliver the promise
of operational efficiencies.
We have many companies
that actually are trying
to build solutions,
micro solutions, mega solutions,
big and bloated chat box
that you see everywhere.
That sometimes it really
fails to really drive
what the customer really needs.
Also, every one of us works
in a large enterprise,
have plenty of supports,
working and testing different agents
in order to make sense,
and to beat the FOMO.
You know, the fear of missing out.
There's something there that
actually we need to explore,
but sometimes we're not sure how to do it.
So, what we have done in Illumia
is take a different approach.
How we start with the business?
So, we sit down with the business.
Our stakeholders are the
CEOs, CMOs, COOs, CFOs.
And we talk about customer care
because that's our specialization.
So, we're purely a company
that drives the service,
customer care with deep domain
knowledge of it as software.
Using a platform that
actually we build together
with AWS and Accenture.
So, we not only have a
very skilled technical team
that actually do the solutions,
but we also have an excellent team
when it comes to customer care.
Our leaders are ex-CMOs.
You know, leading the operations
for large organizations
across the regions.
But that's really important.
That's a big differentiator.
We start with the business.
We start with the outcome.
We empower ourselves with
a platform fueled by AI.
But as you all know, AI is not the answer
for everything that actually we need.
Sometimes we need automation tools.
Sometimes we just need to
redefine how the processes work.
And this allow us to take
some risks when it comes,
you know, to our engagement
with our customers.
So, we start with the business case.
And we commit to the business case.
We make sure that actually we simplify
the implementation of the technology.
We simplify the charger model.
As Daniel says, you know, we
don't use tokenization model.
That actually becomes
a system that actually
is very unpredictable
when it comes to cost.
Actually we consolidate that
in the analysis that actually we do.
And we weave a fixed cost that
actually helps the customer
to take from the fixed cost
statement to a variable model
in a very predictable manner.
So, we try to drive all the benefits of AI
to the outcomes of the business.
So, today we're going to see some
of those demos of how we do it.
We're going to have also
a technical explanation
for those that are more
than the technical side
of what they need to know
to do this and how we do it.
Conversations are key for us, okay?
So, we engage not only
in the first engagement,
you know, when an
interest with a customer,
you know, for example,
comes to our organizations.
It doesn't really matter if it's voice,
if it's text, if it's another API,
we put a lot of effort in creating models,
voices, and connections
that are very empathetic.
Because this is a journey for all of us.
It's a journey that actually
we all transit to say,
"How do I move for a traditional
conversation and engagement
with an organization for
products and services?"
And now how do we move in this new model?
Not only for our interactions
with all the agents,
but also agent to agent.
Agent to traditional models
that actually we need it.
So, those conversations
are not only on the first
line of side that is actually,
how do I take the conversation?
We also take the customer journey.
What else?
What happens behind the scenes
in order for that to happen?
So, we had to redesign
those customer journeys.
We work with our customers
trying to redefine them
in order to make it more efficient
using the knowledge that actually we have.
And if you use a platform
that is not intrusive.
We believe in non-intrusive platforms.
We don't require the customers
to change anything that actually they do.
We help to orchestrate, we
help to create that ecosystems
that actually integrate
not only the agents
that actually we can bring
forward in order to do the things
that actually we need to do,
but also to reuse and maximize
the use of APIs, agents,
ERPs, or systems that actually
the customers may have.
And finally we engage with people.
How we empower them, how
we make the assistant,
how we contextualize the business.
So, those interactions
becomes human agents.
It's a hybrid model that
actually we need to do.
When we engage with people as well,
we can commit to the end-to-end
operational efficiency cost.
And this has been very well
received by our customers.
I have the firsthand experience.
Every time I go there I say like,
"Listen, I'm not here
to sell you technology.
I'm not here saying you
need license or a platform.
I will work with you on outcomes."
And that's a surprise.
At least in Latin America,
it's a model that actually
not all the companies
are challenges are willing to take.
Instead of being a PPT or
a PowerPoint presentations,
you know, with all the
promises, all the things
that actually we are going
to do are going to make
if you hire us, we say we trust our skill,
we trust our platforms, and
we're going to commit to do it.
So, we guarantee the results
when it comes to operational efficiencies.
If something costs a hundred,
we say it will cost 80.
It will cost 80.
And it's our responsibility as a company
that actually has about the
domain knowledge to deliver it.
Omnichannel.
Maybe a conversation starting one channel,
but maybe it's not the most
efficient for it to resolve it.
For example, Roadside Assistance.
You may receive a call
because you need some
support for your car.
But actually you need to
do a localization services
and maybe in the phone
it's not easy to get it.
So, let's do a parallel
connection with them.
Let's open an SMS or a
WhatsApp so we can interact
in multiple channels at the same time.
That's really important
in order to orchestrate
those communications in a
multi-channel environment
and maybe switching them if it's possible.
So, the conversations last a
matter, within the platform.
That means that the model of the super app
is a model that actually
we keep challenging.
We all love to have super apps.
Oh, I want my customer to
install the apps for my company.
But that's not scalable.
If you think about the amount
of services and products
that actually you consume.
How many apps you know
you need in your phone?
So, we're moving a pure agentic model.
What it means is that if
I use interfaces like,
for example, Anthropic, whilst I'm driving
and I need to book, I don't
know, a table in a restaurant.
And maybe that restaurant
doesn't have an agent or an API,
I may use an agent to go to that website
and do the work for you.
Connect the agentic model to
the more traditional model.
Or maybe, I don't know, you
want to open a complaint
in a company that actually has a website,
I will use an agent to
go through that website
and do the complaint for you.
So, we understand the interfaces
and we interact with interfaces.
We try to make it simpler.
So, not all we think
about an incoming message
that actually heard.
But this is ecosystem that
actually comes and goes.
So in our vision, I don't know
if you're gonna need
websites in the future.
Why?
It may be an interface of the past.
We can do an API, we
can do agent-to-agent.
Even we can have an agent that
actually go through an IVR,
makes a call, navigate through the IVR,
and have a conversation with an agent.
It is an intermediate
steps of where we're going.
In whichever state you are,
our platform supports it.
And that's really important for us.
Empathetic agentic model.
In order to do that, we do an
architecture of micro agents.
White labeling micro
agents like Lego blocks
that actually you can put together.
We can create some of them together.
We create some with the
customers and we paralyze them.
In every interaction, we
may have 4, 5, 6, 7 agents
listening to that channel,
to that conversation.
The model that actually you build an agent
that actually you keep
expanding it with more knowledge
actually doesn't work.
We tried it.
Probably you tried before.
What happens is you train it in one way,
then you try to adjust it,
and somehow it start hallucinating.
So, the model is micro agents
in parallel, specialize them.
It works much better.
That means I can have an agent
that actually is monitoring
the sentiment of the call.
If I'm complaining, I may
have an agent that actually
specialize in retention
or specialize in up and cross-selling.
And we need to be able to
move those agents on the fly
because the conversation
may go in another direction.
So, we keep choosing
which is the right agent
in that moment of the conversation.
It's like having different
parts of your brain
trying to compete with one
agent that coordinates that.
We're going to see some of the
demos that actually do that.
But that's really important
for us in order to make sure
that actually we can
engage in empathetic model.
And Danny mentioned a
powerful MarTech solution.
If we keep track of those conversation,
we remember those conversations,
we know what you're doing.
We can create campaigns with agents
that actually analyze your data,
analyze your promotions,
your products, services.
And based on all those engagements,
we can embed
these up and cross-selling
agents in the model
that actually will navigate
through all those conversations,
all those interactions and
be activated on the fly.
So for example, if you are
engaging in a roadside accident,
maybe, I don't know, I may,
it will be an opportunity
to sell you an add-on in the insurance.
So, we send all these agents
to hunt for the opportunity.
And that's why we see the future
also for MarTech solution.
With that, we always try the zero base
or zero load human interactions
in order to make sure
that actually we achieve those outcomes
that actually we commit at the beginning.
So for us,
it's all about the software.
How do we deliver service
as software non-intrusive,
open, integrating multiple technologies,
integrated the systems and the investment
that actually the customer have done,
a micro agent architecture,
a two-way systems in order
to communicate and integrate
agentic worlds with traditional worlds,
and monetizing the
channel at the same time.
That's customer value empowered by AI.
So with that, let me show you
some of the demonstrations
that actually we have.
- Thank you.
Okay.
Yeah, just like Salvador said,
we're gonna see some of the demos
and how this multi-agent
architecture work a little bit
under the hood.
So, let's jump right to it.
(sighs deeply)
Okay. It's the first one.
- [Luana] Hello, Daniel. Thank
you for contacting Illumia.
My name is Luana, how
can I help you today?
Just a quick reminder.
What happens in Vegas stays in Vegas.
- [Daniel] Thanks for the reminder, Luana.
But actually I'm not really
happy with my DirecTV service.
I'd like to cancel it, please.
- [Luana] I understand completely.
And I'm sorry to hear you're
thinking of leaving us.
I see you've been a
customer for three years
and have the premium package,
which includes sports,
movies, and series channels, correct?
What has changed in
your TV usage recently?
- [Daniel] Well, actually I'm
watching a lot more streaming
than what I used to do before.
- [Gustavo] So, we can see the
different agents interacting.
So like us, he said the account
manager sent an analyst.
- [Luana] I completely understand-
- The master one.
- Many customers
have told us the same thing.
The good news is that we
have more flexible options
that might fit your current needs better,
keeping what you enjoy most.
Tell me, do you still
watch sports channels
or do you use news programming a lot?
- [Daniel] Well, yeah, actually
I do watch a lot of sports
and news, a couple, sometimes I do.
- [Luana] Perfect.
I have a proposal that might interest you.
Since you've been a loyal
customer for three years,
I can offer you the
Essential Plus package,
which keeps all sports and news channels
for only $89.90 cents per month.
This represents saving of $39 monthly.
Additionally, I can apply
a special loyalty discount
of 20% for the next six months,
which would make the value $71.92.
What do you think?
- [Daniel] Yeah, that
sounds good actually.
Let's go with that then.
It makes sense for me.
- [Luana] Excellent choice.
I'm very happy to keep you with us
on a plan that makes more sense for you.
I'll process the change now.
The new Essential Plus package
with the loyalty discount
will be activated immediately
and you'll see the value
of $71.92 on your next
bill due on December 15th.
I'll send you a confirmation
email at customer@gmail.com
with all the details of the change
and the list of available channels.
Is that email correct?
- [Gustavo] Oh, that's
an example. Of course.
A pretty easy customer, right?
Not all the customers will
accept an offer like that.
But just to highlight,
you know, the multi-agents
and how they work together and the master
kind of decides what to
answer back to the customer.
And this is like an app we try to...
We did the video, so we thought
about doing the live demo,
but we were concerned that might not work
on this setup here.
So, we didn't know how it worked.
So, that's the first example.
The churn, very big problem
for some of these TV companies.
And then, we're gonna see the second one.
Last one.
- Yeah, there is some delays,
you know, in the response
just to show you.
So, we are going to show another demo
how it works in real-time in conversations
that actually we've record live.
- Hello, Daniel. Thank you
for contacting Illumia.
My name is Luana. How
may I help you today?
- [Daniel] Hi, Luana.
Can you check whether my
bill is correct, please?
- I can certainly check
that for you right away.
I already have your details loaded.
I'm accessing your billing history here.
Looking at this, the average value
of your last TV package
bills was around $189.90,
but this month it came
to $259.90, correct?
- [Daniel] That is correct.
So, why the sharp rise in cost?
- Perfect.
I understand your dissatisfaction
and I will explain how we will proceed.
I will register a dispute in confidence.
Meaning the credit for the difference
will be applied to your next bill,
so you are not disadvantaged
while we conduct the analysis.
During this process,
our billing team will
review the case in detail.
If the dispute is valid,
the credit will be permanently maintained.
If it is invalid, meaning if we identify
that the amount charged was correct,
the credit will be reversed
in the following bill.
- [Daniel] Okay.
Please proceed with
that then please, Luana.
- Perfect.
I have already registered
the dispute under #CL9458723.
The credit of $70 will
be automatically applied
to your next bill
and the analysis result
will be sent via email
within 10 business days.
And just a quick reminder.
What happens in Vegas stays?
Wait a minute, share it with everyone.
- Okay.
Yeah, just a little joke.
- Yeah.
- The avatar, of course,
we're still thinking about it
as a separate channel.
It's not very cheap.
So, you have to really
think about where to use it
and how to use it for the
best of your business case,
but it's a possibility.
The backend is the same
for voice, for text,
or even for the avatar.
It's all the same.
And you kinda choose how to use it.
- So, we're trying with a customer
that actually wants to
do video conferencing.
So, video conferencing
services with avatar
is something possible
that actually you can do.
If there is a need, you
know, on a customer account.
For us, it's all the same.
You know, it's how you deliver
the message in that manner.
- That's right. Yeah.
And now we're gonna see a
little bit more of the solution
and a little bit what's
under the hood, as I said.
- Hello again.
I want to present to you
the NextGen operating
model and architecture
for the Customer Service
Transformation in Illumia
powered by Generative AI
and Agentic Experience.
A model that completely redefines
how customers interact,
how agents perform,
and how organizations learn
from every single conversation.
At the core, a living architecture
that connecting people,
data, and decisions in real-time.
Let's explore it layer by layer.
At the top, we have the control tower.
This is where everything comes together.
Operations are orchestrated,
performance is monitored,
and strategies are adjusted dynamically.
It's the strategic brain
that ensures every part of the
ecosystem works in harmony,
optimizing experience,
cost, and efficiency.
Next, we have the text,
digital and voice channels.
The front door of the experience.
Here live the AI agents
that engage customers
across web, app, chat, and IVR.
Each channel has its own tone,
personality, and context awareness.
Yet all of them connect to
the same intelligent core.
That core is the Gen AI engine, the brain.
This is where the
intelligence truly happens.
A multi-agent orchestrator
manages specialized models,
LLMs, SLMs, integrated
with the knowledge base,
AI content curation, and the
customer interaction database.
Every insight, every
response, every decision
is powered by real data
and continuous learning.
This engine doesn't just answer,
it thinks, predicts, and evolves.
This is the Micro Agents layer
where intelligence becomes modular.
Each micro agent is a specialist AI
built to solve complex challenges
from diagnostics to prediction.
They're reusable,
composable, and scalable,
turning every new use case
into an asset of intelligence.
While customers are served by AI agents,
human agents work side by
side with their copilot,
a single intelligent screen
that provides recommendations,
automates actions, and
anticipates the next best move.
Here, human intuition and
artificial intelligence
operate as one.
All information flows into
the Data Insights Hub.
This is where data becomes knowledge.
Every customer interaction
feeds analytics,
understanding patterns, resolution times,
satisfaction drivers.
And finally, at the foundation,
the Process Optimization Lab.
Here, intelligence turns into action.
Inefficiencies are identified,
processes are redesigned,
and new automations are deployed.
It's where the system learns from itself
and the cycle of improvement never stops.
Together, these layers form
a self-learning ecosystem,
an architecture where every conversation,
every agent, and every insight
contributes to a smarter, faster
and more human customer experience.
- Okay. Yeah.
So, one of the many important
parts of the architecture
that we need actually to serve
is when you think about customer care,
there are a lot of spikes in the demand.
So, you're a constant, and
then a constant demand.
And then for example,
there's like an important game for DirecTV
and the spike on usage is like crazy.
So, we tried to use as most as we could,
serverless components.
Very few exceptions
for the telephony part.
Apart from that, everything
else is serverless.
And just a curiosity,
on the first week that
we went into production,
there was like a, I
think it was a Thursday
where they had a lot of
games of the national teams
in Latin America, Brazil,
Argentina, everything.
And we just basically
hit the max that we had
three times over at nine o'clock at night.
It was crazy.
And we were able to, using of course,
AWS serverless components
to support that spike.
We're just gonna see one more call
and then a little more of the components.
- [AI Assistant] Hello. Good afternoon.
(clears throat)
I'm your DirecTV virtual assistant.
Who am I speaking with?
- [Mark] Very good
morning. I'm Mark Smith.
- [AI Assistant] Hi Mr.
Smith. Pleasure to meet you.
Hm, I saw that you requested
a copy of your bill.
Is that what you need?
- [Mark] I was waiting for the bill
and it still hasn't arrived.
Can you send me a copy?
- [AI Assistant] Sure. I'm going
to sort this out right now.
Let me look up the information for you.
Perfect.
I found your account and confirm
that you have the Electronic
Bill Service activated.
The bills are sent to the registered email
that starts with the letters
MS and ends with @gmail.com.
Is that email correct?
- [Mark] Yes.
- [AI Assistant] Perfect.
I'm sending your bill to your
registered email right now.
One moment.
Done. I've sent it.
You should receive the bill in your inbox
in the next few minutes.
Is everything all right?
- [Mark] Yes. Perfect, thanks.
- [AI Assistant] Great.
Remember that from MiDirecTV,
you can download previous
bills if you need them.
Is there anything else
I can help you with?
- [Mark] No, everything's perfect.
Thank you very much for your help.
- [AI Assistant] It was
a pleasure to assist you.
Have an excellent day.
- Okay.
So, as I said, it's mostly
based on serverless components.
Our main database, it's OpenSearch.
And that's using that and Redis.
That's how we transfer
contact from one channel
to another to support true omnichannel.
So, since the behind the
scenes, the brain is the same.
So, if you're invoicing,
in the IVR, for example,
and you go to a text channel,
context completely transfer
to the text channels.
It just keeps talking to you on the text
as if you were talking on
the IVR in the first place.
And that's OpenSearch to help with that.
We use Amazon Transcribe
as a speech-to-text.
Very happy with that.
Our main component is the Amazon Bedrock,
which gave us a lot of
flexibility to change the LLMs.
So, we started with one,
and then we already have,
we're using four different
ones and we keep looking
and seeing what's coming to use the best.
What's works best for that
specific agent, right?
For the voice, most of the voice
that we heard actually
are from ElevenLabs.
So, the text-to-speech startup.
We also use as for our RAG,
the knowledge base from Bedrock as well.
And for the orchestration of
the agents, we use Versal AI.
So, the OpenSource using node.
And yeah, the guardrails
we, they're also in AWS.
We implemented them.
And this is just to show part of the,
some of the LLMs that we use.
So for a faster, simpler,
quicker response,
we use Amazon Nova, mostly Nova Lite.
We use a lot of Anthropic.
So, we use Sonnet 4, Sonnet
4.5, and the Haiku 4.5,
which is the fastest one.
Just came out about a month ago.
So, actually, we're
constantly on the lookout
for whatever's coming,
and to see whatever works best for us.
And of course, cost is also something
that we keep looking and
trying to see what's the best,
that works best for that use case, okay?
Yeah, I'm just gonna go to the next one
and pass it down back to Daniel.
Talk about the results.
- Okay. Thank you, Gustavo.
Let me talk about results, yeah?
And first of all, let
me talk about DirecTV
because we make a huge transformation.
When we started the transformation,
we used to have thousands of
CSRs around Latin America,
unionized in different countries
with more than 10 years
working as a CSR, yeah?
So, we had a very, very
challenging situation
at the beginning.
In rewriting the customer interaction,
the re:Invent of the
revolution that I mentioned,
first 12 months of implementing
the first pieces of our solution
with decreased the total
cost of ownership in 25%.
Yeah?
We are aiming to have
a 45% reduction on TCO
during the length of the entire problem.
So, when we, Lumi, talked about
our aspirations and results,
we are getting the
results right now, yeah?
Something that was very
important for the business
that DirecTV and Sky is
managing, registrations, yeah?
How the customers are being
registered in our systems.
When we implemented the
solution in the first weeks,
we increased three times the
success on the registration.
When we talk about how much we resolve
when the first four weeks,
we increase that into 84%.
So, these are results that matters.
We are not talking about aspirations.
We are talking about real
results that we are facing.
And you know, when we talk
about Gen AI, we talk about,
you know, in some cases
hallucinations, yeah?
We filter 97% of the interactions
without zero hallucinations.
We still have 3% that we need challenged
during the operational side that we need
to continue to work on on that dimension.
And obviously, something that is not.
We cannot decline even though
we want to get deficiencies
and reduce the total cost of ownership.
NPS is very important, yeah?
We had customers that were very frustrated
in the way that they interact with us
and we are improving that vis-a-vis
that we deliver the use
cases into the new paradigm.
And you know, let me talk about
two or three things
that for me is important
and I will ask also
Salva to join me on that.
What we are doing right
now? Commercial expansions.
We are expanding our portfolio of clients.
So, can we comment on what we are doing
in terms of commercial expansion
in our different markets?
- Actually we are serving
already 10 million customers.
You know, so we have a
client zero that actually
is one of the largest
tech medias in the region.
That means that actually, you
know, it's a proven platform.
It's something that
actually we are expanding
and talking about the
customers in all Latin America.
Indeed yesterday, you know,
we had a meeting with the AWS team as well
and they asked us when we're
going to America, to the US.
And it's mainly because
the purpose, isn't it?
This is applied technology.
If you think about where
everything is going,
you know, the other day the Blackstone CEO
was talking about where to invest.
Those are rule-based companies
that actually have domain expertise
supported with a large ecosystem,
working with technical partners
that actually what we're
doing in order to expand it.
So, all over Latin America At this stage,
we are only 18 months old as a company,
but with big dreams and big ambitions.
- Thank you, Salva.
Another two or three things that we'd like
to comment with you other
than the technical side,
the demonstrations, and what we are doing.
What we expect on our people?
We are working very hard.
You know, we have not
only a huge expertise
in terms of how to deal
with Gen AI at scale,
but we also have a huge expertise
in terms of operational processes.
And we expect three things.
I continue to mention
this in different places
when we talk about my
people in the region.
I expect people with passion.
I expect people with ambition
and great souls, yeah?
I don't expect any anymore
and any less of that.
And I think we are building
a team on that direction.
And on the other side,
we are building a team
of partners, you know?
And we, our partners become our friends
because we work so close
with them that sometimes
we are not seeing who is
in which company, yeah?
So, this is very important.
And this is for us a precondition
on what we are doing.
And we don't want to do only this.
We are working right now
in Latin America sometimes.
The other day a person
approached me and he said,
"Are you planning to stay
in Latin America only?"
No, we're not planning to
stay in Latin America only.
We want to keep our focus in
order to expand our company
in such a way that we can manage.
Salva is managing the expansion in a very,
you know, in a way that we are
focusing on deliver results,
increasing the number of clients.
And this is very important for us, yeah?
And just for closing,
and then I will open to
questions and comments.
I would like from you not only questions
on what we are doing.
I would like to understand your visions
and your comments on that
because obviously all of you
are having similar challenges
in your companies.
But we have a purpose, yeah?
Obviously, we are a company.
We want to gain money.
We want to expand our footprint
and we want to deliver what we promise.
But if you look into our
logo, we are Illumia, yeah?
Where empathy meets AI.
We want to be the co-pilot of human beings
at the time that they
interact and navigate
the different ecosystems
that they use for living
and the different experiences
that they are managing.
This is our purpose.
We are there. We would like to innovate.
We are not trying to be the ones imagining
how much the Gen AI or the
artificial intelligence
will impact our business.
We are ready to serve the way.
And how to deliver that and scale
into our business processes.
So, this is where we are.
Thank you for the patient
and to listen to us.
And I will open the stage
for questions and comments.
I want to receive also your
comments, yeah. Thank you.
- Thank you very much
for all your attention.
- Thank you.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you. Thank you.
(audience applauding)